los opositores después llega juan voy
dos salieron el día de hoy de manera
presencial a participar en la consulta
popular organizada dentro y fuera de
venezuela para que todos los venezolanos
mayores de 18 años puedan expresar su
opinión de si desean unas nuevas
elecciones presidenciales libres y si
además rechazan el proceso electoral
parlamentario realizado el pasado 6 de
diciembre aunque este evento no es
vinculante los participantes esperan que
los resultados lleguen hasta la
comunidad internacional para que ejerza
una presión sobre el gobierno de nicolás
maduro porque creemos que la consulta es
un medio más una oportunidad más de
poder dar a conocer al mundo lo que está
pasando y podamos construir un poco más
a ver cómo salimos de estas pesadillas
que nos tienen ya 22 años esté en plena
angustia y cada día más pauperizada la
situación cada día más cuestionado cada
día más amenazador
con la victoria bolivariana es el nombre
de esta actividad organizada con dos
diputados el pueblo patriótico que
ganaron en las elecciones del pasado 6
de diciembre y el presidente nicolás
maduro les pidió a los parlamentarios
que se organizaran se concentradas en
las distintas plazas del país en
oposición al llamado de la consulta
popular de huawei de consulta popular
que estamos convocando la oposición en
este caso why do no tiene legalidad
alguna
ellos lo saben estoy engañando al pueblo
es una consulta que nos parece de ningún
tipo de parte legal en el momento
nacional que no es más del gran polo
patriótico a partir del 5 de enero
el gobierno de nicolás maduro necesita